I I know you're gnarlier than I am
Stephen when we're doing the trick shots
and I'm tapping out at like a hundred
times you'll just keep doing it until
you get it and you're like 300 times 400
times then when I do get it it wasn't
good enough right
yeah you know and that's what it would
have hit me when you because there was a
thing that you said where you were like
doing a a bouncy ball and you're like
this is for my late hamster Doyle and he
said it a hundred times and then it
started [__] with my head and I had
to go in the bed because I was like
starting to crack I was starting to lose
it yeah and you just hear him in the
stairs going this is for my late hamster
Doyle and he said like 300 more shots
because I can handle it up to 100 times
sure doing it for 10 hours like are you
what the [__] going on that's a great
question that's a great question no I
mean after the 10 hours I was like I
don't need to do another Marathon stream
uh ever again probably because the
physicality of it is the challenge it's
the it's the throat and the vocals that
could potentially [__] it all up it's
not so much the mind but what's
interesting is with freestyling I think
the reason I love it so much and have
loved it for so long you know since I
was 11 12 years old when I first started
trying to figure out how to do it is um
it's sort of like a access point to you
know Flow State or like what people call
getting in the zone or whatever where
it's like
the thing is it's it's so challenging
that it requires my full attention uh
but because I practiced it for so long
I'm able to accomplish it so it's like
consistently rewarding you know it's
like every new word that I get thrown or
grab and work into a line it's like if I
can pull it off it's like [__] yeah you
know in that moment it's like yes and
then it gives you this excitement and
this energy to kind of like continue on
that path and and so it sort of becomes
this thing where you have blinders on
and all the external noise and all the
you know all the voices in your head
that are going on all day and all that
just sort of gets muted and you just
have this one singular Focus that's
consistently rewarding and holding your
attention and kind of pulling you
forward so
um I don't know I guess I guess the 10
hour stream was like an exercise in the
depth of Flow State you know like how
deep can I really get in there and stay
there it's crazy yeah
like shopping on Amazon I do and good
news is Stevo's butt wipes for your
butthole are available on Amazon
and if you want a real bundle of a deal
you can get Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole plus Stephen's butthole
destroyer and Stevo's butt wipes for
your butthole it's the butthole bundle
available on Amazon right now
yeah dude